you write that the quote archetypal big
cycle
governs the rising and declining empires
and influences everything about them
including their currencies and markets
the most important three cycles are the
ones
you mentioned in the introduction
the long-term debt and capital market
cycle the internal order and disorder
cycle and the external order and
disorder
cycle
can you describe this
big cycle
there are two orders
there is an order by a sip order i mean
a system
how the system works
um so there's an internal order
that is the internal governance system
and it's usually set out in a
constitution or some agreements
um and then there's the world order
uh how the world system so for example
in 1945
at the end of a war
which is basically a fight for
determining the world order
the winners of the fight
got together and created the world
system as we now know it 44 they created
the brenton woods monetary system that
determined the money pretty much
and because the united states won
and had 80 percent of the world's money
gold was money then and had 80 of the
world's gold and it was half the world
economy and it was the great military
power
the uh order was built around an
american world order so that the united
nations was in new york the world bank
and the imf were in washington and they
built that new order so classically
you have a war to determine whose rules
were following
and then you have
the new water being constructed
after that there is usually period of
extended peace and
prosperity
peace suits prosperity
um and so there's not and the reason you
have the peace is because no one wants
to fight with the
um dominant power you know you're going
to lose you've surrendered there's been
the surrendering they carve up the world
they say what it's going to look like
who's going to control what and then um
you come into that period of of peace
and then
prosperity where then there's uh
um a working together usually at that
point you've wiped out a lot of the
debt you've wiped out a lot of the
um
issues the class warfare and so on
and then there's good working together
so those great periods
such as the industrial revolution in the
late 1800s
or what we've experienced in the
post-world war ii period are peaceful
and prosperous periods
led largely by the dominant world power
over a period of time
since really 1500
and maybe before but really 1500
when the
dutch invented capitalism and what i
mean by that they invest invented the
first capital markets the first stocks
and the first stock market
that since then capitalism has been an
effective tool for building wealth
because it got resources into the hands
of inventive people um that's when we
moved from agriculture to the importance
of inventiveness of people they got
resources
and then they built that prosperity
in that process of doing that
they create wealth gaps naturally those
who make a lot of money
um
make a lot more and than those that
don't
and
it also produces opportunity gaps
because
for example
those who earn a lot of money have that
wealth
they have the power to educate their
children in a way that others don't
and
the gaps grow
and also the debts grow at that time
when they go around the world with their
competitiveness they
earn a lot of money so for example the
dutch the dutch empire
learned how to build ships
um and that would go around the world a
key ingredient of this improvement in
this cycle is the improvement of
education and by education i mean the
skills that come from education but also
civility the ability to deal with well
together so the dutch invented ships
that could go around the world and they
had military power but they were also
very inventive society 25
of the world's new inventions came from
the dutch
and so as they went around the world
they also brought their currency
and they brought their military
they needed their the currency they paid
for things um and that currency and then
the more that happens the more that
becomes a reserve currency
and then they have their military so
they need their military strength and so
you see it evolve in all of those ways
but over a period of time
um as they become more successful and
more expensive
they became they become more expensive
um
then and
newer countries come along like um the
uk
um
then
learn to build ships from a lot the
dutch and could do that less expensively
and also when they become more
expensive so less competitive and also
the work ethic begins to change
they believe that since they're richer
they can enjoy life more they don't have
to work quite as hard and so you start
to see the tilt
now you start to see the development of
the top and when you have a world
reserve currency
that allows you to borrow a lot of money
because those who want to save
want to hold your money and that means
that they'll lend you money and so those
countries get deeper into debt
so you see that they gradually lose
their competitiveness
and they
and they get themselves into financial
circumstances which are not good
and they have large wealth gaps
which set the stage for downturns and
when they have down turns
the first question is do they have
enough money and traditionally you know
money is is resources
so you classically see that the coffers
are bare
that they're spending more money than
their
than they are earning and they run out
of money in the coffers
and their granaries are empty rather
than stocked so that they give them the
buffer
and as that deteriorates that's that
worsens conditions
and if they have a rival power that's
also challenging them they see greater
internal conflict over wealth
and then they have the problems
internally and the problems externally
which usually results in an internal war
or an external war that leads to the
change in the to the new world order
and to you the dutch empire is a good
example that
the british
what are some of the key examples that
you think about in the book
of this process that followed the big
cycle
well the leading reserve currency
empires but it applies to all the
empires
um
were the the dutch the british uh the
american and the chinese
but
you could follow the same pattern
in the book i it was very important for
me to not just use words and concepts
because that's subjective it was very
important for me to use
actual measurements so as you see in the
book you can see every level of this you
can see where is the education level
what is the military power each one of
those and you could see them back going
over the 500 years
and so um you can see the arcs and the
composition of those
arcs and what you see is really in most
countries in most dynasties you can see
that but you also can see through those
numbers
the health
of those countries today
um there are there are statistics that
you could that are in the book that show
what is the level of education what is
the letter level of economic output what
is the level of
um military strength what is the level
of a number of different measures of
strength so that you can then compare
that and i think that because their
objective measures of strength that you
could see change
that shows the picture of where we are
today and i think one of the most
important things about the book
is that it allows people to monitor how
those things are transpiring i think for
policy makers
um
you know are your policymakers doing a
good job and there's so much
subjectivity in that
but i think it's very simple
if those lines on the chart are
improving if your health index is
improving
then you're moving toward a better life
so that's what the book works like also
it was used to create a model for the
future
in other words there are cause effect
relationships
everything that happens has reasons
causes that preceded it that made it
happen and so by having all those in
numbers
one can see the probabilities of certain
things happening so um
that's what that's what you see in in
the book it's not just you know ray's
interpretation i didn't want to make it
raise interpretation because i don't
know if i'm right
you